make sure everyone sees the [ __ ]  ingredients bad guys there's sunflower  oil in this [ __ ]  why do  I debate of Wellness culture it actually  makes me mad folks stop producing Foods  down to a single ingredient yes oat milk  contains some sunflower oil to improve  the mouth feel there's actually a few  different types of sunflower oil some of  which are higher in monounsaturated fats  and others higher in polyunsaturated  fats and looking at this label I'm  seeing more monounsaturated fats and  omega-6s So nutritionally speaking I  think this is a pretty nice looking  product that I also happen to know  tastes really great so just a little Pro  tip here folks buy what you like and if  an ingredient doesn't work for you no  problem choose something else but can we  stop with the elitist food shaming it is  really not a cute look next